Cavalry officers lead the way at the
start of myanmar's Armed Forces Day
Parade a limousine carrying the military
leader in the rear
as Dawn broke over the huge parade
ground in the secluded Capital napador
tens of thousands of soldiers marched in
formation
addressing his troops Minong Lai said he
would stop at nothing to defeat what he
called terrorists those who continue to
resist military rule the terror acts of
the national Unity government and its
Lucky the so-called people's Defense
Forces need to be tackled for good once
and for all myanmar's military and the
government also needs to take action
against these terrorist groups which are
trying to devastate the country and are
killing people
after the ground troops came the heavy
weaponry
huge artillery pieces and Rockets tanks
and heavy armor
overhead a display of air power
fighter jets and helicopters purchased
from Russia and China deployed
frequently over the past 12 months
hundreds of civilians are reported to
have been killed in airstrikes
a display of pump Grandeur and Military
might but this all not to inspire
confidence but rather fear and those who
still defy military rule
for those on the receiving end it's a
constant struggle to survive the United
Nations estimates that nearly one and a
half million people have been displaced
by fighting since the military coup
we heard the sound of artillery fire and
we told the children to run and hide we
don't know if the shelling will happen
during the day or at night we can't do
anything and only want to escape from
this situation
this wasn't a display of high-tech
Weaponry instead brute force and
Military might
but if the intention was shock and awe
some didn't get the message this huge
display the marching parades you know
the the militaristic speeches this is
all about the tatmadot trying to
intimidate the people of Myanmar and I
don't think they're buying it anymore
but the message from myanmar's generals
is clear elections are unlikely until
they've taken back control and they're
prepared to use all the weapons at their
disposal Tony Chang Al Jazeera